tile this is nice because just like for the Torah code we have geometric locality for this code so we don't need
to move cubits over long distances to measure stabilizer generators and the fact that the Z and X stabilizer generators always act non-trivially on
exactly the same sets of cubits is also nice for reasons connected with fault tolerant Quantum computation which I'll
say more about in the next lesson color code are quantum error correcting codes that generalize this
basic pattern where we do essentially the same thing except with different graphs for example here's a graph with
19 vertices that works this gives us a code that encodes 1 Cubit into 19 and it happens to have
distance five these are called color codes by the way because one of the required conditions on the graph is that the faces can be three-colored meaning
that we can color the faces with three colors and we never have two faces of the same color sharing an edge the
colors don't actually matter for the code itself we simply have x and z stabilizer generators for each face regardless of its color but the colors
do turn out to be important for analyzing how it works so those are two very well-known
families of codes but there are many other constructions that are known including ones that are based on ideas similar to these code families as well
as completely different ones a specific example of a Quantum error correcting code that was recently
discovered by some of my colleagues at IBM is known as the gross code which is so named because a gross is a dozen
dozen or 144 in particular this code encodes 12 cubits into 144 cubits and it has
distance 12 I won't explain how this code Works in detail it's similar to the Tor code except that each of the
stabilizer generators now involves two additional cubits that are just a little bit further away it doesn't have a planer embedding
like a surface code but it does have a so-called Baner impeding meaning that two layers of cubits are needed rather
than one it falls into a family of codes called byari bicycle codes and what's particularly remarkable about them is
that they're much more efficient than the Torah code or a surface code in the sense that a lot more cubits can be encoded while simultaneously they
tolerate roughly the same rate of Errors for the gross code an additional 144 cubits are needed for the syndrome
measure so the total number of cubits required is 288 which makes it a very promising candidate for today's
technology and that concludes this lesson which has been on constructions of quantum error creating codes including CSS codes the Torah code and a
glimpse at other Quantum Code constructions including surface codes and color codes I hope you will join me for the
next and final lesson of the series on fault tolerant Quantum computation which addresses the challenge of Performing
comp computations un encoded Quantum States using operations and Computing components that are themselves prone to
errors goodbye until then